My name is Roland Schwartz and I am a
computational biologist
at the European Bioinformatics Institute
The major part of my research
is the development of new statistical
approaches and computational methods
for improving what is called phylogenetic
inference
the reconstruction of the tree of life
or parts of the tree of life.
One of the most fascinating things about
DNA for me is that it's digital
and consists of these four characters As, Cs, Ts and Gs
so it lends itself to the analysis with computational methods
and we're developing and improving those
methods that look
in DNA sequences for these changes so we
can say
in the course of evolution from animal
1 to animal 2
one of these As for example in a
certain position in the sequence
has evolved to a C.
I don't think there's really a typical
day in my work
I think it really depends on the project you're working on
so even though I'm a computational
biologist not all of my time is spent
in front of the computer
I think an important part of all the
projects that I do are
meeting the collaborators talking to
people, to biologists and to the medics
to try to understand their point of view
and their problems,
but also withdrawing into a quiet corner to
read some papers and try to
get your head around a certain project and problem before you return to the
computer and try to analyse the data
and so on.
One of the greatest things about my line
of work I think is
how inter-disciplinary it is.
So apart from my own line research I work with biologists, with clinical scientists
and every time I help them
analyse their data
help them solve their problems I myself
learn a lot of new biology
as well as a lot of new computer science
and maths.
I believe that careers are this sort of evolutionary
processes in the same sense that
random changes in the genome occur and
give rise to all these new organisms
I think it has been random changes in my life
that have made me first go into bioinformatics
and then later end up here at the EBI in
Cambridge
and so while I believe that you should
have a rough idea of where you going
I think you cannot prepare for the
completely unknown.
If I remember back in my days in school
while I enjoyed certain subjects of course
I always thought that learning was usually
learned for your parents or for your teachers
or to have good grades but then later
when I started doing my PhD where I exclusively
could focus on the actual
research that I was interested in,
suddenly I found it really exciting to
learn new things and
I think that's one of the most rewarding
things you can have in a job is too
get paid for learning.